hey and welcome to let's play roller
coaster kin 3 episode 72 today I decided
to play some ambien Japanese music in
the background as I commentate this so I
have no idea if this is going to make me
more mellow or [ __ ] why am I even
talking about that today I am going to
build this building of course in
rollercoaster Queen 3 and as we go on
actually the delay between me
live-streaming stuff and me making
videos doing the commentaries and
editing videos and rendering it it's
starting to get bigger and bigger and
this is a good thing from the standpoint
that you know this means that I can
release more videos but it also means
that I've got to hurry the [ __ ] up and
actually get some videos done so that's
what I'm doing right now this episode is
going to be all about a couple buildings
around the main street and yeah buckle
up for some Main Street event adventures
because the next 5 episodes I think are
still going to be all about the Main
Street and getting all the buildings
around this area done and it's
definitely the primary focus of the
beginning of this park because I also
feel like this is the type of thing
that's you know when you when you feel
like it you really want to do it and you
can finish it and do a good job on it
but if you decide to save it for later
then it'll always be that annoying thing
that you still have to finish in your
Park and you always procrastinate and
you're always like yeah I'll come back
to that later but you secretly never do
so I want to avoid that today this
building over here is a bit of a weird
one in the sense that it's a bit of a
different style and by different I meant
that it's actually quite similar to my
usual stuff it's that same sort of
Alpine style but really I would call it
more German because the Alpine style is
definitely different doesn't have as
much what we're going on definitely has
different roofs and more use of wooden
walls and stuff but this is definitely
something that I want to come back to
later because I do want to use the
Austrian style for something possibly in
the park because I don't see that too
often but yeah this is just going to be
that standard Germanic thing that you're
pretty used to except it's got the
slight touches like you can see from the
Disney Castle over there with the arches
and the tower of course and that little
thing in front of it so it still has
of a special touch and I still think it
goes pretty well with the main square
we've got here though I must say it is a
bit similar to the entrance building
which might be a problem but I I'm not
too sure about that I guess it works and
there is the Gorman ball that there's so
many Gorman balls and all my building
this is just something that you can
always add when you're like mmm still
need to add something to this building
and when you have some sort of call
tower or some roof that could use some
spicing up just slap Gorman balls in it
and it's good that's pretty much my
whole life philosophy at this point what
the actual purpose of this building is I
have no idea and this is a bit of a
problem with the main streets so far
like the majority of the buildings are
going to be gift shops and little things
but there's a lot to be desired for the
actual practical use of the buildings
and so far nothing is actually planned
to be a dark ride or anything of the
sort so that might be a bit of a problem
in the future
might want to work on that but my first
kind of idea here we still finish the
buildings and get that all looking nice
and finished and then move on to the
cool attractions and stuff and the
rollercoasters of course because you
know at some point in time I'll have to
be I will have to have worked on this
park for 8 episodes and have yet to
build an attraction that's a bit weird
so definitely want to work on that as
well now when it comes to this building
I've been very quick to batch this
building and be like you know this is
the same type of building we've seen a
thousand times we don't really want to
see this anymore
but I guess this is a good time to just
give a little tip about this general
style of buildings because what is the
main reason that the Alpine theme I
think is becoming so overused or is
already so overused in the roller
coaster can 3 honestly it's been
overused for a very long time it's
mainly because of the fact that it has
very easy-to-use sets and I know a
couple people actually admit that they
just use the Alpine King because it's
easy to use and it has some great sets
in it but the disadvantage with that is
that it's easy to set a good building
it's just easy to build a decent
building in the ALP
style thanks to the good sets and the
amount of knowledge that there is about
the theme but then again it also really
presents a pitfall of the fact that your
bowling is going to look like every
other Alpine building out there and one
of the best ways to avoid things usually
but this especially counts for alpine is
to try mixing in some different sets so
even though it might seem weird to mix
in the walls from the Disney Castle and
to get some arches in there or some
elements that usually don't even belong
in the Alpine theme just don't hesitate
to throw them in there because if
something looks somewhat different than
in the game it's definitely going to
look better and even from a theme park
perspective it wouldn't even be too bad
because something that I only just
recently realized again is the fact that
everybody is quite obsessed with realism
in rollercoaster kanthri
but then again a theme park is not a
real-life city and this is something
that you should realize this doesn't
count of course if you're building real
life cities in Monaco take a three which
is also quite a common thing but in
theme parks you can exaggerate things
and add elements to certain cultures
that you normally don't have in them or
blend things because after all it's a
theme park and if it were exactly to be
realistic and just 100% like the
real-life counterparts why would you
even make them in a theme park there's
just something about the theme park that
it's also a bit of a Fantasyland and
it's a place for the things that you
don't have in real life and kind of want
to see anyway so I guess let's do
something to keep in mind that I
recently thought of no idea why I said
this I was just like hmm might as well
throw that out there there was actually
a bit over thought that I had at the
time I think when I was recording this
also I completely messed up on that gate
that was kind of a funny little stream
moment there I place the gates and then
I was like damn it Patrick I hate you I
want you to die why does this gate not
work and then I basically screamed at
the creator of the custom CD reset for
10 minutes and then somebody in the
stream said you placed it the wrong way
around and I was like oh I'm sorry so
that was a bit of an awkward moment
there this building will be that kind of
I don't really know where I was going
with this building at the MoMA
I just figured that I saw these posts in
shyguys main street eights I think it
was and decided that I wanted to use
these posts and then threw some wood on
them and then actually looked pretty
good and it kind of looked like that
kind of yeah what would you call it it's
a bit of a Victorian ish style but it
still has more wood elements and it's
more refined in a way but yeah I guess I
can just call it Victorian and then I
even decided to get those ironworks and
it's almost team hunk in a way but yeah
that's just the general idea of this
building I'm still not too sure about
this building yet because when it's
finished I still feel like it could be a
bit better it still it still is a bit
flat especially because it doesn't
really have any cornices to speak of and
it has no big pillars or anything like
that and the steampunk theme in general
is something that I want to completely
avoid with this park because we've seen
too much steampunk as of lately and
especially well and I can't I can't
speak for other people but I've seen too
much steampunk lately it's been a very
recurring theme and I've also done it
for quite a while now some come to tired
of steampunk
we've had that steampunk area I mean
that steampunk period let's just move on
to other things that's kind of when I
felt like doing this point in time so
that I did I guess that being said
though I still have no real idea what
kind of themes I'm going to get in this
park because I've been taking up all
these suggestions and putting them in a
small file just to read out the themes
if I really want to you know come up
with things and remember what I wanted
to do but now I've got a huge list of
themes and and there is no correlation
between the entire list at all
whatsoever and that's a bit of a problem
so I'm thinking about maybe keeping the
park to eurasia and making it theme to
you raised here instead of for example
just Europe or the entire world but that
also doesn't really seem like the best
idea so what I want to go for in general
is just a park with many different areas
with all kinds of cultures from all over
the world and especially the colleges
that nobody really
cares about or well no it's not like
nobody cares about them
but they don't get in upload when it
comes to theme parks such as Vilonia and
Latvia and Transylvania stuff like that
but the issue the issue that I have so
far with it is that I'm not really sure
what kind of correlation all those
themes are going to have within the
theme park in general so that is still
something to find out if anybody has any
ideas on how I should do it then don't
hesitate to leave a comment I can't
promise that I'll take on every
suggestion but it's still great to just
brainstorm a bit and maybe I will take
some suggestions so anyway that's it for
this episode thank you for watching and
I'll see you on the next episode